what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and it's looking like
Kevin feige really does have insanely
huge plans for the next two faces of the
MCU and then beyond that that's right
Kevin feige has all of his plans for
phase five phase six and of course phase
seven and Beyond which we're not really
surprised about it's Kevin feige he's
already said that he thinks about 10
years ahead but I gotta say what we've
recently been hearing about the end of
the Multiverse Saga which we still have
a few years left on but the end of it is
sounding like it's going to be simply
fantastic and then the start of the next
Saga is where I think the MCU is going
to get even more exciting than we've
ever seen it before however it is
sounding like phase six and the end of
the Multiverse Saga is truly going to be
very very hard to top and if you're
thinking X-Men then you're right however
perhaps not the X-Men that you are
thinking about as we've heard news today
that makes sense that we've actually
been spec calculating about for a while
that states Kevin feige is going to say
goodbye to the fox X-Men first before
introducing the new X-Men and this makes
sense and I actually really love it and
it is very sentimental because Kevin
feige started his Marvel career with the
X-Men as I talked about yesterday the
first film that Kevin foggy worked on
was the X-Men film in 2000 that film
kick-started his career and he worked
with Hugh Jackman then as well and
actually helped Hugh Jackman kind of
become Wolverine he was an associate
producer on that film but of course he
would go on to become co-producer
executive producer all the way up until
now where of course he is the president
of Marvel Studios so in a new report
from Grace Randolph I believe she
mentioned it today she is the one
reporting that Kevin feige will say
goodbye to the fox X-Men first and
Avengers Secret Wars and then after
Avengers Secret Wars he will bring in
the new X-Men into the MCU in Phase
seven and I'm actually okay with this
because I've been predicting this for a
while that the X-Men wouldn't come until
phase seven it just doesn't seem like
there's enough time between now and the
events of Secret Wars to introduce major
X-Men characters but rather a cool thing
that they could do is after Secret Wars
after they've worked with a whole bunch
of X-Men a bunch of different X-Men
variants they could question where the
X-Men where the mutants of their own
Universe are the main MCU X-Men which
I'm kind of curious to see what Doctor
Strange is going to go on to do after
Multiverse of Madness because you would
think that that's going on in his mind
where are these extremely powerful
heroes in my own Universe even though he
probably doesn't think they're too
powerful considering how the Scarlet
Witch simply obliterated them but
nonetheless anybody would be curious to
see if those people existed in their own
universe so I'm curious to see what
Doctor Strange 3 has in store for us
because I think since Kevin feige is
going to say goodbye to his X-Men in
secret Wars we'll probably see some
other X-Men and other characters that
he's worked on before pop up in the mcob
before Secret Wars and we already know
one one has already been confirmed and
it's the big one Wolverine hi hi
how are you you have questions yes Hugh
Jackman is returning to play Wolverine
alongside Ryan Reynolds in Deadpool 3.
and it's been said that Deadpool is
going to visit other parts of the fox
universe and see other characters from
the X-Men the Fantastic Four and who
knows what else this is seemingly the
start of Kevin feige's Grand goodbye and
I really love this for Kevin feige but
also for the actors as well because
plenty of them have stated that they
would have loved to have been in the MCU
love to have been a part of it and now
they get to in some way shape or form
they will have been a part of the MCU
and then after Secret Wars I feel like
they could truly move on from their
characters so pretty much everything
that we wanted to see from Spider-Man no
way home and Doctor Strange and the
Multiverse of Madness it sounds like we
are truly going to get that in secret
Wars and it's the perfect opportunity to
do so I think Spider-Man no way home was
great probably the best to come from
phase four of the MCU but it wasn't on a
super huge scale it was just two other
Spider-Man and a few villains come into
our universe and it was done by a spell
it wasn't really Multiverse hopping and
Multiverse of Madness was supposed to be
a lot of Multiverse hopping but it
didn't really happen we kind of only
stuck to a few universes and only saw a
handful of variants whereas Secret Wars
is sounding like we're going to have at
least 50 different variants of
characters appearing so let's talk about
what exactly is going to happen and
which characters we can expect to see
and this character list excites me so
much it's so exciting but first big
thank you to Mint mobile for sponsoring
this video most people know about mint
mobile because of Ryan Reynolds but most
people don't know about mint Mobile's
amazing quality now I live in the
mountains and service isn't too good
however mint mobile sent me a free plan
and I get better service with their plan
than I do with my other provider but
what's crazy is their plan is so much
cheaper mint mobile offers Wireless for
just 15 bucks a month they give you the
best rate whether you're buying for one
or a family and at mint mobile family
only start at only two lines all plans
come with unlimited talk and text plus
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network plus mint
Mobile's Modern Family Plan lets you mix
and match data plans so everyone gets
the amount of data that's right for them
and you can use your own phone and keep
your same number and contacts so to get
your new Wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month including the Modern Family Plan
go to mintmobile.com Cosmic that's
mintmobile.com Cosmic cut your wireless
build down to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com Cosmic so Grace in her
video seems to think that Kevin feige is
going to focus on the original X-Men in
which I agree I think this would make
the most sense like I said that was the
first project he worked on now of course
that's not all we should expect but
let's talk about these original X-Men so
of course we're going to be getting Hugh
Jackman back we already know that but
then Ian McKellen as Magneto which I'm
dying to see Patrick Stewart of course
as Professor X which we kind of got in
Multiverse some Madness not the same one
from the fox universe so we'll be
getting the same one soon James Marsden
a cyclops who I absolutely love and I
think he's been crushing it lately Holly
Barry a storm who is just iconic I love
her she played a perfect storm famka
Jansen as Jean Gray hopefully Rebecca
Romaine can return as Mystique and then
Anna Paquin as Rogue who I actually
didn't like that much but would be
really cool to see nonetheless seeing
these characters return is definitely
going to be some of the best Nostalgia
any of us fans could ever dream of and
the great part about this is it actually
fits the story it's not them doing it to
just do it that's what secret Wars is
all of the variants coming together a
vast multiversal War fighting for the
literal multiverses survival and we know
it's not just going to be the X-Men and
the X-Men variants coming together but
the Fantastic Four and the Fantastic
Four variants as well now of course we
have two iterations of the X-Men and the
Fantastic Four from Fox and even though
Kevin feige seemingly wants to give a
proper goodbye to his original X-Men and
probably the original Fantastic Four I
would expect some of the X-Men first
Class to appear as well and maybe even
some of the Fantastic Four with Miles
Teller and Michael B Jordan after all it
would be kind of cool to see Michael B
Jordan play the Human Torch and
killmonger and have those two characters
side by side completely different people
however I do think Kevin feige will
focus on the original fantastic forecast
in the original X-Men cast the most and
I trust that this goodbye is going to be
really great because it's going to be
very personal for Kevin feige but then
after Secret Wars the mutant Saga will
begin this is when we'll start to get
New Mutants in the MCU not the New
Mutants but new X-Men in the MCU and our
own X-Men team will start to form now of
course they've already been kind of
doing that Miss Marvel dropped the name
mutant and we know that Namor is a
mutant from Black Panther wakanda
forever as well also that's not a
spoiler they confirmed before the movie
even came out that he is a so if you
haven't seen it don't worry I haven't
spoiled any scene there they just
confirmed beforehand but these are just
teases nothing has really been put in
place yet but now it makes sense Kevin
feige wants to say goodbye to the old
X-Men and then start the new saga after
the Multiverse Saga start it off with
X-Men which is a perfect idea because
it's original and fresh at that point at
that point The Avengers will have had
six phases all to themselves The
Avengers and all the other Heroes that
fall along the lines with them the
Guardians of the Galaxy Spider-Man
everybody that we've seen so far and
then after it'll be time for the X-Men
and the Fantastic Four to take the
spotlight of course we'll probably still
have an Avengers team but the spotlight
and the focus is really going to be on
the new people coming in and I like this
idea because it keeps the MCU fresh and
I think the end of Phase 5 and phase six
on the Multiverse Saga in general is
going to be pretty big so as far as the
future of the MCU is concerned I'm
really excited for it and I think it's
going to be very bright but hey let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below are you excited
about this is this something you want to
see let me know don't forget to give the
video a like And subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news for
live updates you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf